- In one of the sessions.
I'm like, oh, you thought
that was controversial?
Wait til you see what's coming, man.
Wait til my session (laughs).
(upbeat dance music)
(techno music)
Good morning everybody.
Welcome to day, day two, I guess.
Had a rough night last night,
slept just under four hours.
The jet lag's still seeping in.
But grateful to get some sleep
because I got a busy day ahead today.
So I woke up around 4:30
in the morning Paris time.
Managed to say good night
to Nina, which was great.
Get some work done, have
a shower, do some YouTube.
Ray Dalio started following me on Twitter.
Might be doing a collab.
Ray Dalio is a multi billionaire investor
who's worth like 16, 17 billion
dollars something like that.
Then I got some good work
done, checked in to some
YouTube videos that we have coming up
and so I'm excited for that.
It's now 7:30, I'm going
to go grab a coffee
and head to the convention center.
It kicks off at eight.
I'm going to get my badge
and get ready to be there
for the opening intro.
Hopefully grab maybe an hour
or two of sleep after lunch.
And then five o'clock, or maybe
it's 5:30, I take the stage.
So pumped about that.
Let's do it.
Day two.
(upbeat techno music)
Got my coffee.
Forgot how bitter Starbucks coffee was.
This much importance.
But I'm grateful to have
some kind of coffee here
so it should be good.
(upbeat techno music)
I've got a little bit of time to kill
before the event starts.
So I'm going to get on social
media, answer your questions.
(upbeat techno music)
I made the wall.
I made the wall of my video, guys.
Look at that.
So my plan, my usual networking strategy,
sit in a really busy
area, people walking by.
Let me show you.
Sit in a really busy area
with people walking by.
Wear the shirt, and do my thing.
Get on social media, start posting,
and people come up and talk to me.
It's my networking
strategy, works every time.
I love this wall too.
So you can see me on the wall.
Every time I post it ends up
going there so, it's working.
This is the room, super pumped.
Going to be here speaking in,
I don't know, eight hours,
I don't know what time.
This is going to be fun
though, check it out.
Check out the size of this room.
It's legit.
And I get to sit right here.
The room is starting to
fill up, check it out.
It's starting to fill up!
We're going to go soon!
Almost showtime, I'm
just sitting on stage,
chilling as people come in.
The entrance is over there.
People come in, say hi, again,
network strategy 101 with Evan.
Sit in a public area, have the t-shirt on
and people come and say hi.
Works every time.
(uplifting music)
- [Announcer] Ladies and
gentlemen, welcome to Paris!
(audience clapping)
(uplifting music)
- First part of the day is done.
It's a fun event, fun crowd,
I'm so pumped to get on.
I'm going to, they went for
a coffee break and lunch,
and some product sessions that
I'm not going to be in on,
so I'm going to go back to the hotel,
try to catch a couple extra
snoozes, hour or two, refresh.
Wake up, go over my presentation,
one or two more times, like a back.
So I got to be back here
for 4:30 and I'm excited.
One of the guys was talking
about how somebody made a
kind of controversial remark
in one of the sessions.
I'm like, oh, you thought
that was controversial,
wait til you see what's coming, man.
Wait til my session (laughs).
We're going to bring it.
Anyway, back to the hotel.
(uplifting music)
So it's four o'clock, I have
to be at the stage at 4:30
to practice, to get set
up, mic'd up, all that.
And then at 5:30 I go live,
I'm super pumped about that.
Did not sleep very well at all.
I think the combination of
the coffee being in my system,
(phone rings)
oh, they're calling me, wake up call.
Hello?
Combination of the coffee,
that large Starbucks coffee,
plus being worried about
the alarms not going off,
so that one actually just
worked, you heard it.
I set one on my phone and I set one for
the phone that was here.
I'm always worried that the
alarm is not going to go off,
and so it prevents me from sleeping.
And also just thinking
about the presentation.
And I always put a lot
of pressure on myself
to do a great job because
I'm spending time away.
It's four days away, pretty much.
Three days away?
Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, three days away.
Still a lot of time away.
And so this has to work, you know.
Not just because I'm getting paid,
but I'm missing out on other
opportunities to help people,
so this has to be great.
And so those combination of things made it
not conducive to sleeping.
But it's okay, and I'm
really trying to think of
anytime I complain to
see the positive side.
We talked about that
earlier on in this vlog.
So I'm really grateful
that I have a hotel room
that's right across the street
from the conference center
that I can easily come back to.
I'm grateful that I have a
nice, soft bed to sleep in,
at least relax in and not be
forced to be out and about
losing more energy.
I heard a baby cry for a little bit
and so I'm really grateful
for that baby not freaking out
because I've been in hotel rooms
where the baby cries all
night and that sucks.
And it's pretty clean air.
There's a lot of smoking
in general in Paris
and I get allergic to smoking
so it's great that it's so clean.
So that's the positive.
I had a shower, I changed,
new shirt, look at that.
Special new shirt, this
is the performance shirt.
And I'm pumped, I'm excited
and ready to go speak
and I'm going to take you guys with me.
All right, I'm here.
It's almost showtime.
We're getting set up.
There it is a Club Talentsoft in the back.
Here's the room again, going
to be filled with people.
I'm pumped.
- Let's call our last speaker
today, last but not least,
he is a successful entrepreneur
on a mission to help
one million entrepreneurs,
just that, right.
He is the author of this
absolutely great book,
find Your One Word, and
is a rockstar on YouTube
with more than 700,000 subscribers,
ladies and gentlemen,
please give a warm welcome
to Evan Carmichael!
(audience claps)
- I love being in a room full of leaders.
I love being in a room full of people
who want to be inspired,
who come to learn,
who want to improve themselves,
who want to take the
knowledge that they took here
and apply it to their business.
And most importantly, I
love being with people
who want to take action,
because that's what we do as leaders.
Everybody stand up, just quickly.
Quick exercise, everybody stand up.
Get the house lights up a little bit.
I didn't prep these guys for it.
Everybody stand up.
I want you to put your hands up like this.
Everybody put your hands up like this.
Here we go, all right.
When I count to three,
what we're going to do
is we're going to turn
to the person next to us,
we're going to give them a high ten,
and we're going to say,
you're a leader baby!
(audience laughs)
Don't laugh, I'm serious!
Okay, you're a leader baby!
One, two, three.
- [Audience] You're a leader baby!
- Other side, other side!
You're a leader baby!
- [Audience] You're a leader baby!
(upbeat music)
- Crushed the speech.
They're now celebrating with a giant ball,
ten year anniversary.
(upbeat music)
So the event is wrapping up.
Lots of fun.
Got to meet some new fans,
which has been great.
Take a lot of selfies,
answer some questions.
People are just kind of chilling now.
Networking, grabbing some
food, some champagne,
the cheese, the mozzarella cheese is nuts.
I had to have a little,
but Shawn's going to kill me, my trainer.
But otherwise, everything's
been going really, really well.
Just going to hang out a little bit longer
and then I think there's some
other activities planned.
I just go where my handler tells me to go.
And then I connected with Nina,
so super happy about that.
She's doing well, she
wants me to bring her back
something special from Paris,
so I got to find something
to bring home to Nina.
Should be food related,
because Nina loves her food.
So I got to find something that
is not too caloric, but tasty
so that's going to be the challenge.
If you guys have, well, I
can't ask you for advice
because by the time you
watch this I'll be home.
So, anyway, having fun.
(upbeat music)
My trainer's going to kill me for this.
All right, had a great
dinner with a savvier.
And heading back to the hotel.
So that restaurant that we
went to was run by a friend
of his and he got some custom
stuff there at the end.
So filling, but so amazing.
Blew past my calorie
restriction for the day
so Shawn is not going to be happy with me,
but the rest of the day
was actually pretty solid,
so I think we'll be okay.
Going to head back to the hotel,
hopefully catch ahold of Nina.
It's 10:30 Paris time, which
means it's 4:30 back home,
so hopefully be able to get ahold of her.
Connect and see how she's doing.
Pack up and get ready to
head back home tomorrow.
If I have some time, maybe
do a little bit on the town.
And 11:00 a.m. on the
flight come back home.
See my wife, I'm excited.
Good morning, good morning, good morning.
There's a fire alarm
going off in my building
and just this morning they
had this crazy fire happening
in London where it spread
super fast and hit 125 families
so I'm watching on CNN and
then the fire alarm goes off
in my building so it's like,
okay, I got to get out of here ASAP.
Hopefully everything's okay here.
It's a little scary.
I woke up, had ten hours of
sleep, which is fantastic.
In the first two nights I actually had
three and a half to four hours sleep.
So it feels good to have a solid ten.
I didn't get a chance to
do anything this morning.
I'm waiting for my ride to the airport,
it's going to come in
about 20 minutes or so.
And right now I just want
to get out of this building,
with the alarm going off.
I think I made it, whoo.
So I'm out.
Let's see where, what's going on.
Get back to the lobby.
I got to get home.
I got to see my wife.
All right, everything's okay.
Time to breathe, relax, and be okay.
Waiting on my ride to the
airport and get to fly home.
(uplifting music)
One of Nina's friends
and former co-workers
collects Starbucks mugs in every city.
But not just cities he goes
to, cities other people go to.
And so he reminded Nina
that on my trip to Paris
I need to pick him up
a Starbucks Paris mug.
Usually you can find them in the airport.
So I'm looking for
Starbucks, for you Tony.
I should be sitting in the
Air France lounge right now,
relaxing, doing some
work, but I'm hustling
trying to find a Starbucks for you, Tony.
You better appreciate it man.
(cheerful music)
So the options at the Air France
lounge are a lot healthier
than the options at the Air
Canada lounge in Toronto.
Check out what I got.
Got some salad and tomatoes and cheese.
Shrimp, mushrooms,
chicken, turkey, banana.
Going to eat, do some
work, then board the plane.
They've got power here on the plane,
which means I can get some work done.
So I'm either going to be doing videos
with this wifi on the flight
or I'm going to be working on my new book.
(cheerful music)
Just got off, got to get through Customs
and then hopefully I get to see Nina.
She's just leaving work
too, so we'll see if we can
sync up our schedules
otherwise got to take Uber.
Really hope I get to see Nina.
(cheerful music)
Look who I found, look who I found.
It's Teemo and Nina!
Kisses to the wife first.
Hello mister.
I miss this.
We talked a lot about Nina.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- She missed me too.
Okay, well thank you for joining me.
Hope you have a great
weekend, continue to.
- Believe.
- And we'll see you soon.
- Much love.